emmanuel macron l'annoncé dans son
discours du lundi 13 avril les
événements rassemblant du public ne
pourront se tenir au moins jusqu'à la mi
juillet à saint quentin en yvelines le
premier festival pulsations était prévue
à la fin du mois de septembre de cette
année mais le confinement a poussé les
équipes organisatrices a repoussé le
rendez vous d'un an bon sens mélanie
poker bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78
c'est ce dont vous allez parler avec
votre invité et willy france fasse des
salles del r bonjour bonsoir
alors l'annoncé du report du festival
peut surprendre puisqu'il était prévu en
septembre mais le confinement que nous
connaissons depuis le mois de mars a en
effet impacter votre préparation
tout à fait oui l'organisation depuis le
mois de mars est devenu extrêmement
compliquée puisque évidemment plus on
s'approchait du festival plus les choses
devenaient urgente et il fallait être de
plus en plus réactifs les contacts
n'était plus réactif les programmateurs
étaient tous beaucoup plus intéressés et
on le comprend par les reports des
artistes de leur spectacle et c'est que
par une réservation sur notre festival
donc voilà on a beaucoup réfléchi
travaillé par visioconférence comme tout
le monde et nous avons opté pour une
décision stage nous at on dit voilà
mais pourquoi au nom supplémentaire
c'est pour mieux préparer la prochaine
édition à venir
alors voilà c'est ça c'était la question
était est-ce qu'on laisse qu'on le dit
faire ou est-ce qu'on leur porte et donc
on a décidé de le reporter de date à
date puisqu'il est reportée au 25 et 26
septembre 2021 de façon à ce que les
choses soient claires c'est un festival
qui veut être qui je suis et donc sur
une période qui sera dédiée donc on veut
rester sur ce calendrier là et puis ce
temps qui que nous nous donnons en fait
va nous permettre de construire des
parties de l'accompagnement qu'on
n'avait pas eu le temps de construire
notamment un club des partenaires
puisque c'est quelque chose qui nous
tenait à coeur de construire un club des
partenaires avec tous les partenaires
qu'ils soient institutionnels qu'il soit
un privé
qu'ils soient associatifs artistique
voilà donc on va avoir le temps de
construire ce club des partenaires et de
faire des événements qui sont des
événements précurseur pourtant ce club
des partenaires il va quand même se
tenir un petit peu cette année en
septembre
vous conservez un rendez vous malgré
tout alors voilà on va créer un premier
rendez vous donc le partenariat glee de
loisirs restent neutres est effectif
nous avons tout de suite rencontré toute
l'équipe avec la directrice 1 lille de
loisirs et qui a été très favorable au
report qui est également favorable à ce
club des partenaires et à des
rendez-vous et le premier rendez-vous de
ce club des partenaires aura lieu le 27
septembre à lille de loisirs mais il va
consister en quoi c'est que tous les
partenaires se rencontrent vous pouvez
vous ici aussi partagé par exemple le
mans votre vision exactement où on va on
va créer plusieurs rendez vous celui ci
sera le premier ce seront des temps de
rencontrer des jeunes échanges entre
tous nos partenaires qui viennent de
milieux et de cadres professionnels très
différents donc la dynamique que
construit l'animateur se bat pour
pouvoir prendre la vraiment tout son
sens puisque cette année suffit
supplémentaire qui nous est donnée va
nous permettre de développer ça oui
c'est de ces liens ces contacts quand
vous londres et on voudrait développer
est ce que ça vous permet aussi de voir
peut-être plus grand avec plus de rendez
vous plus d'animations vous vous gardez
le cadre que vous aviez déterminée pour
cette année alors le festival de
pulsations est déjà très ambitieux donc
les artistes que nous avions déjà
réservé entre guillemets nous suivent
tous donc c'est très bien
les structures artistiques onirique
c'est la même chose nous suivent
donc voilà on a déjà un festival
extrêmement ambitieux dans nos dans nos
tiroirs donc il n'est pas vraiment prévu
qu'on soit plus ambitieux par contre ce
qu'on voudrait développer c'est voilà
tout toute cette douce et lien tous ces
échanges
vraiment ce soit le grand événement
fédérateur
voilà et j'en profite pour remercier
toutes ces personnes qui depuis le début
bénévoles institutions travaillent avec
nous qu'ils ont très bien accueilli le
festival et qui continue de poursuivre
cette démarche avec mercy françoise de
saldé l'air donc la première édition du
festival pulsations aura lieu les 25 et
26 septembre 2021 et merci à vous
également mélanie